do you remember game genie this is what
would happen if Mario had a magic
mushroom what I love about this is the
game genie codes themselves are
hilarious the codes is using our ze big
pop and I date in Conker's Bad Fur Day
you actually fight living poop diarrhea
it comes alive it's after you know it's
a freaking scary no it is the most scary
villain ever can you imagine if your
poop grows out of the toilet and they
wanted to attack you that's a coli that
did happen to me last week actually but
I had these weird tacos this WTF was
submitted to be sauce by the staff Sarge
and I couldn't be more thankful splinter
cell chaos theory
this guy has I don't know some sort of
broken spine or something and it looks
like he's this is the holy grail of
every dude's the fantasy I don't see
what's so weird about it I think it's
amazing if you've got more that you like
leave them in the comments because I
want to see more if you want daily video
game news and comedies subscribe here
exactly good point Andreea and if you're
a really cool person check us out on
Facebook one of my favorite things to do
is to explore kind of the weird glitchy
you're not supposed to access them they
haven't really been developed areas of
World of Warcraft the coolest one I just
found this yesterday's is the ability to
go underneath Orgrimmar and you jump off
of this fence you're not supposed to
jump off of and all of a sudden you fall
into this weird desert and the entire
city of Orgrimmar becomes invisible it's
so trippy it's like almost kind of a
cool place to go and hide and meditate
you
[Music]